they're on i'm professor of islam here
at the University I'm Dean abundantly
undergraduate colleges and currently the
director of the Middle East Institute
and it is enormous pleasure to welcome
you here today and to welcome our
panelists at this absolutely momentous
moment in the history of our societies
this evening obviously we're going to be
discussing Libya primarily but Libby in
the context of the broader our people
and it's my pleasure to be able to
introduce to you our distinguished
panelists each of whom will just stand
when I introduced them eventually they
will end up up here for the panel
discussion let me begin with Professor
Peter Brandt who is currently professor
history at Temple University his reached
research and teaching interests include
modern Arab studies comparative world
history and political economy his most
recently completed book on world is
about world history and he's refocusing
on modern Egyptian history and will most
probably be carrying on a long-term
project comparing Egyptian and Italian
history I among his many publications
are the books beyond Eurocentrism a new
view of modern world history Islamic
roots of capitalism Egypt from 1762 1840
and medical tourism in Arab and Egyptian
history
professor Ali asked me that is chair of
the Department of Political Science and
looking chair of Liberal Arts and
Sciences at the University of Notre Dame
achieve me New England before it is live
he's the author of the making of modern
Libya state formation conversation and
resistance forgotten voices power and
agency in colonial and postcolonial
Libya post orientalism critical reviews
in North African social and cultural
history paranoia is the author of four
extraordinary books of poetry thalia am
risco zodiac of echoes and is my eclipse
he's translated nine books of
contemporary our poetry by a number of
extraordinary clothes he has won
numerous awards among them the Academy
of American poets fellowship prize the
pen American Center award for poetry
translation a guggenheim fellowship and
an Alf recorder fellowship from
Princeton University and any a
translation grant and three pushcart
prize
his poems have appeared in poetry the
Kenyon review antioch review best
American poetry and many other journals
and anthologies we are enormously
privileged to have this distinguished
group of panelists with us tonight but I
would also like to thank especially one
of our own cambia students whose really
put this entire panel together in i
would say about 20 minutes given the
current political situation use it when
Huntsman is an accomplished scholar a
Libyan by descent and an individual of
extraordinary energy and commitment to
the study of the Arab world and so it's
my pleasure to introduce Youssef
captain's to be a student in the college
that I run so that makes me especially
proud thank you and if you got wrong or
in gracious I would like to briefly
discuss three Libya's one
Libya before februari 17th 2011 which
I'll refer to as in Debbie's Lydia to
Libya of today februari 17th to March
third which are I'll offer to as to the
beyond the people and finally three
build me up tomorrow definitely from the
moment colonel mohammed invicta thien's
fellow military officers came to power
in a coup on September first nineteen
sixty-nine the Qaddafi regime has faced
constant challenges to its power in the
early years of the regime the United
States and its allies felt that
stability can be achieved in Libya
through an anti-communist military
regime that would partner in the cold
war policy of containment as a result
Western powers alive themselves with
Lydia in a relationship of mutual
assurance although this relationship
soured rather quickly over the past
forty one and a half years and despite
numerous atrocities perpetrated by the
regime and its funding of countless
civil wars terrorist fruits and then the
last 25 years or so Islamic
fundamentalists Western powers have
mostly employed a carrot and stick
approach with Gaddafi's Libya as a major
oil and gas producer the biz petroleum
reserves are the ninth largest in the
world and its natural gas reserves are
23 despite numerous sanctions against
Gaddafi's Libya
were ultimately lived in the biz
hydrocarbon resources have remained on
the world market and in 2004 the United
States was restored bilateral relations
with Libya removing Olivia from the list
of state sponsors of terror but sadly as
recent events were confirmed the Gaddafi
regime has not renounced her due to a
2010 extension of the his unconventional
weapons disarmament unfortunately
granted to the regime Libya possesses an
unknown quantity of mustard gas evidence
of which has been discovered during the
past two weeks after the 2003
rapprochement with the global community
and the 2004 and me 2004 restoration of
bilateral relations with the United
States one apparently got his sons set a
son again that the emerged as the heir
apparent to his Father's throne
academics policy analysts government
officials and members of the media the
world over help libya's monumental
about-face and Seth was promoted and
increasingly characterized as a
progressive reformer he was said to be
enlightened educated facing a heavy
burden that the son of the leader he
gave speeches decrying would be his
political situation calling for the
establishment of a new constitution and
rebuilding into the in civil society
sadly we were all fooled if at least
libya began to revitalize his military
capacity signed contracts with major
arms manufacturers in europe including
fabrique nationale general dynamics UK
and a licensed greek subcontractor of
the small arms manufacturer heckler &
koch begin that regime also signed major
crimes in russia and france for the
delivery of war planes helicopters and
armored vehicles
thankfully most if not all of the
armored vehicles tax cuts and
helicopters are yet to be delivered
according to UN Security Council
resolution 1970 ratified unanimously
last weekend by all members of Security
Council the conductor regime is barred
from purchasing any more arms much of
the Gaddafi regime is destructive
foreign policy is not well understood
and the bees interconnected nature with
the African continent in the Middle East
well documented is not quite in a
publicized the 1980s witnessed the birth
of several us to the via proxy wars in
the African continent one inch add
another nurturance again through the
militarization of Darfur and third the
biz attempt to achieve hegemony over
both chat again while the guppies
actions in chad and the larger african
continent are no secret the regime's
method of conscription of young libyan
men remain has remained failed although
the conscription asian olivia is a teen
boys as young as 13 have been kitten
from their homes transported to chat and
left with nothing but a Kalashnikov and
instructions is something you'll fight
it happens are a favorite method
employed by the regime useful in styles
from the voices of all those who speak
out against it Olivia today
when protested protests erupted in
Tunisia on December 17 2010 after
Tunisian Mohamed Bouazizi
self-immolation and a mass uprising
through peaceful protest cheese
President Zine El Abidine de nada out of
the country on january fourteenth soon
after protests in Egypt successfully
successfully forced the resignation of
President pristine melodic and with the
fall of the Egyptian autocrat for the
first time in nearly 40 years deluding
people saw their transfer independence
of dictatorship februari 17th was
designated the Day of Rage by members of
the regime opposition both win country
not sign Albert however protests again
two days really unfair e15 in response
to the arrest of attorney factory idea
if there was a human rights activist and
attorney for the victims of the 1996
massacre of political prisoners in Libya
abu salim prison
we're more than 1200 prisoners were
executed over the course of several
hours over the last six hundred days
protests in Libya have been messed with
unspeakable brutality by the regime in
anticipation of the uprising living WT
imported and continues to import
mercenaries mostly from sub-saharan
Africa from countries such as we share
Chad Zimbabwe Ghana Sudan and Molly as
the world has come to realize the Libyan
military was not a conventionally
organized force but a series of
semi-autonomous groups including some
regiments controlled by leader sons self
has taken on the role of spin doctor and
major architect of the master of living
people much of eastern Libya including
Bolivia's second-largest city of
Benghazi has been liberated from the
Gaddafi regime well if that maintains
control of her Tripoli it's others as
well as sears and survive now we have a
western city in Libya as well as several
others claim into hydrogen regime and
allegiance to revolutionary forces
one of the major success stories of the
Libyan uprising is Benghazi its
residents have banded together to
rebuild civil society publishing their
own newspaper and as we speak Benghazi
is launching its own independent
satellite television station opposition
government leaders have united across
tribal and regional lines to form a
provisional government led by former
Justice Minister Mustafa harlingen una
pilota Qaddafi regime is on last leg and
numerous politicians soldiers and
diplomats infected from that in record
time the regime continues to brutally
murder kidnap and punish the million
people in Tripoli violence has planned
countless lives and kidnappings breaks
and meetings our daily occurrence and no
one's immune food stocks medical
supplies are nearly depleted the shelves
of Tripolitania and supermarkets are
empty
there is no food
there is a desperate shortage of blood
across having all Libyan hospitals and
relief efforts have so far been able to
meet unable to meet the challenge the
Libyan government has sent warplanes
across the country dropping bombs on
anti regime forces as well as protesters
in the last 48 hours the regime has
attacked both Braga and estonia in
eastern libya casualties have been
recorded although it a statement to Sky
News yesterday claiming that the
bombings which is to quote frightened
killed militias and gain control over
oil installations tadaga houses one of
the largest natural gas power plants in
the eastern region Libya and get
destroyed literally leave hundreds of
thousands of lives in dark
Olivia tomorrow while it is involved to
claim that Olivia of tomorrow descending
into civil war and will fall into the
hands of roaming fundamentalists due to
the fact that that they had Latin
political Civic and bureaucratic
institutions it must be remembered that
even ended up his limit before the
uprising basic institutions existed they
were in deep decay exceedingly corrupt
and on the whole neglected but it is not
simply an open desert of warring tribes
since the monarchical period and
throughout the Gaddafi regime Libya has
exhibited universities social security
program Universal forms of health care
unemployment insurance and other welfare
programs Libya's institutions are in
dire straits and cease to function but
that does not mean they do not exist or
cannot be rebuilt many of the games both
within the country and in the dice por
on our highly skilled and educated they
simply need a chance to build Olivia of
tomorrow
you